three seconds 103 players 1857 average
rating time handicap t night round 1
round 1 against T night we just played
in a 5 minute one we got to play again
what is this
okay I have a center I want a big center
push that night a walk around I'm gonna
do it right now all right
kick this night away and then jump in to
jump into f7 maybe not so easy though is
it not a tall castle and then do what
next I should have considered that I'm
gonna get trapped or something my bishop
is gonna get hit and my night I'm
getting rocked back right now I don't
even know what that move does okay I'm
in trouble they're definitely in trouble
that is that rook gonna be taken yes it
is I get that pun difficult to defend
I'm on this as well on that part oh I'm
in check ah miss that I'm on this pawn
on this rook and then do what next I
should have done that I come all the way
back Knight takes pawn here I could take
that around the night this is very
annoying oh man oh man I'm in trouble
I'm big trouble my rook is actually
defended I missed that
my queen could take this pawn with check
oh I feel like I need to back up cuz
it's a watch over this my rook is there
and where's the main are there any mates
ah this is so tough nine seconds oh no I
got it I got to do this I have to take
that's not a good move I'd smothered me
I've made I'd made I made I've made
oh are you kidding me what kind of a
start to a tournament is dad I had
smother made I missed it and I was dead
there would have been Bishop checks why
am i already the wind is knocked right
out of me this is not even right that
should not be the that should not be the
start to any tournament ever ever no
tournament should ever start like that
and finish with the smothered mane
I don't care if I'm the one that's
having to do that check please let that
work oh forks hang on let me hit the
Queen first they'll never suspect that
one let me play here I want that Queen
give me the Queenie I still want the
Queen I have force I still want the
Queen or the rook can I get that Queen
oh man that took the wind right out of
me check let me do know I'm gonna come
back just for fun mixing these time
burners no no no this is better I have
the Queen now
ah that worked out well they realize
that did not realize that the time I
don't even really um how much time is or
how many points does the leader have I
couldn't even look could not even look
just anything time burners time burners
anything burners okay I should not have
taken that I just don't want any time to
come off the clock here anything
anything anything at all
tricky night back to chairman 600 2012
12 10 I have and there's a bunch of
sixes I'm one of them
oh man okay double those points I always
get beat to dump I didn't mean to do
that move ah I didn't want to do that
move that was silly ah man I don't have
a center now I'm blaming it on that
mouse lip I blame the mouse lip I blame
that mouse lip that was not a good idea
to weaken that square by the way that
was what you call it no no that was what
you call no no you should never do that
never the night playing there is good
ah I gotta go back so my LightSquared
Bishop is dead I'm in trouble I'm
playing in reap I'm going in reverse
here hang on I'll take with the pun take
with that pawn can I post up with this
bishop right here actually let me do
that could we Queen we have a queen
trait please all I want is a queen trade
clean trade please actually it's not a
good idea to do that I'm dropping upon
I'm dropping a Pawnee I should still be
able to defend this though right can I
defend this please is it defendable I'll
keep that night honor that Bishop out
watch out for the tricky Knights where
are you at where you at my king is a
fighting piece or is he I think I have
to get rid of that oh oh oh oh can I pin
this I got to do that move I think that
rook why is that rook so dangerous I
just opened up another file oh it's not
gonna be good I don't have anything I
mean I'm gonna be in check I gotta do
this move no way I only have 7 seconds
also that's a nasty pin to be in let me
tell you let me tell you I don't have
any way out
any way out can I get this poem
ah no time no time or no position also
ah I don't have anything no time or
anything I'm dead back to tournament
land oh that one's stung that was so bad
d3 I played t3 I should have been able
to recover oh man
okay let's focus now let's focus I got
to do stuff that's reckless right now I
have to play recklessly okay I want to
play on the F file please get on the F
file or not oh man let's do this they
were gonna smash through out that square
one thing now I can't castle really
can't I whoa this can't be right can it
I sneak my Queen over defending stuff
aren't I I was just ready to play Queen
g6 next I can't do that okay I could
take here and then block this check ah
man it's so tough to recover now from
just even a single loss that's gonna be
tough isn't it yes it is yes it is yes
it is that nights gonna kill me I just
want to get rid of that Knight get rid
of that Knight trade off just one pair
of rugs look at my look at my knight
over here these pawns just keep pushing
I have to sneak over here in blockade I
think he needs to whoa that was almost
you know what you know what that almost
was the adobe flash gambit oh I can't
even move my knight I'm gonna do this
it's wrong though isn't it
I'm dropping that night I am officially
dropping that night there goes the piece
up that I had quick checks
where are the quick checks I'm glad I'm
glad I'm aus lift that one is all I ever
have back to tournament ten I have a
mountain to climb 21 minutes remaining
though can he come back is the big
question everybody wants to know I want
to be able to say yes I want to be able
to say yes could I be able to say yes
please
all right I get my Queen here oh they
they did that I'm gonna hit that Queen
he's gonna block at the bishop right
inside castle get my rook playing and
then do what that was another Mouse slip
another Mouse slip take with the night
and then all right I want to break up
this structure get it this Square and
this pawn is going to be passed very
soon very soon I want to secure my
knight on f5 that's the next plan secure
that night right here and stop the
knight from playing there that was that
was the threat I believe I have this
covered maybe kick this night away oh
I'm on that was that missed get that
night away give a check stop the knight
from playing here still keep the knight
out of that square pawn push I was gonna
push here if they pushed there I think
the knight is close to trapped pawn push
next that's very difficult to defend
against resigned time resigning time get
my king over here to defend anything
pawn push pawn push again back to term
in 1872 eight games in oh man 72
thirty-eight thirty-seven twenty minutes
remaining that's a lot of games that is
a lot of games less than twenty minutes
remaining
oh man
okay maybe maybe maybe wouldn't have 72
if I wouldn't have lost it's my own
fault it's your own fault for not
winning like who are you trying to blame
here trying to blame can I get here
please my dark squares are gonna be
weakened no I take this night can I do
that please I take that night I'm gonna
take here one of these squares first
what the Queen's off can I get the
Queen's off
okay the Queen's are off okay my King
has to recapture so I'm guarding this
square my knight wants to be able to
move I feel like I'm in trouble no my
king is here to watch over that now I
got to do this with my rook grab this
pawn I'm gonna try it got that pound
pound push pawn push okay that I'm gonna
do this I want to stop this advance
although it's probably still gonna come
in or not let me just play here still
available pawn push because the bishop
gets that pawn alright now it's not so I
think I've secured stuff although the
Knights gonna jump to one of these two
squares can we trade nights I just want
to make sure the Knights off the board I
think that that night could have been
very annoying to me very annoying and
now hop is a color bishop ending what's
going oh oh oh oh why did I drop that
pond I didn't mean to do that 17 seconds
oh why didn't I see that that was
actually a thread oh man come on I'm
dropping this pawn but I think I'm okay
with that one I'm okay with the trade
we're gonna dance back and forth a
little bit I think I was ready to get
made it or something something close to
it I could take that back up and then
push my pawn to victory lane less than
three pawn pushers pawn push pawn push
pawn push Queen anything back to
chairman 28 110
110 110 56 I could see 56 or even 60 110
is crazytown
that is crazy to known right there I
need to get my f-pawn involved can I get
that working no I have to guard this pun
I want to hang on to my light square
bishop can I do that Bishop takes pawn
might be available gain some space
avoid exchanges they're avoided I want
to kick this night away and he might be
trapped now go to c6 I thought he had to
go to a six if he was hit now he has to
go to c6 yes I'm just going to do this
castle castle you definitely want a
castle there's gotta be sacrifices take
care I really don't want to do that
alright i'll castle come over here
Knight g5 okay I'm gonna play my knight
right there okay this is opening up I
need to kick this Knight out of here
Bishop takes pawn is available maybe I
should have moved my Knight and I would
have been hitting g6o the Knights gonna
jump in here now no he's not he's gonna
play here I'll back up he's out of play
my bishop is very good kicked the night
away land a check right here best
Knights actually trapped he's cooked 33
to 22 seconds open a file take this pawn
opening the I'm on this on the bishop I
have this covered mate threatened to
mate to threat Bishop here first I think
this is unavoidable not seeing a defense
to it no matter what back to Turner 41
3109
86 69 54 this is a 109 er Andrew G
Andrew G I have to chip away Andrew G is
up there at what 109 points wow that is
a lot of points man
how's everybody getting so many points
okay pawn push the Queen's our intention
hitting at that point oh oh I got the
Queen keep this closed a little bit and
get this palm pushing next I really want
to guard this square if I could do that
I'm happy and I'm a little bit more
happy
stop this advance want to really do what
okay this is ugly
cuz this is a nice long diagonal so my
plan here is to get rid of that light
square bishop and then I would crash
through at that point but whoa okay I
could do that push here expand expand
still you have to guard my light square
bishop like this
come here guard the pawn and stopper up
there pawn push I could do could hit
this rook a little bit passed pawn I
still want to get rid of that light
square bishop gonna do it like this he's
just in too good of a spot too good of a
spot get rid of this Knight it's too
tricky with check stick around here and
I'm push I'm finally sort of caught up
on the clock let's come back I'm okay if
that bishops taken come over here I'm
gonna take that 1511 seconds pawn push
takes I want to get this pawn I got it
oh I should have taken that first huh
I'm going to take that seven seconds and
push anything time burners time burners
go fast Pond go fast anything anything
anything I probably shouldn't have done
that move can't breathe did I win
i won apparently 170 oh man man that's
crazy 170 okay
oh that was almost the Adobe Flash that
was almost the Adobe Flash
that's check okay
and now jump in here I'm on that light
square bishop grab that pun my opponent
really do that bishop here is
threatening tricky stuff against the
Queen Queen here it's threatening me I'm
glad I saw that one let's back up let's
back up my computer really going that
slow that I let's just take that out
take that one out Queen trade I guess
I'm threatening me h7 regarding this the
Knights ready to be trapped the knight
is trapped he is officially trapped and
about caught up with the clock are we
gonna have resignation it's tied up 34
seconds each resignation back to term at
170 107 104 I'm at 70 arm armchair 12
minutes remaining
okay um all right let's control this
Square actually why am I going for this
is there possibilities for a quick kill
in this setup or we are going to find
out fast
Queen 85 I'm not quite sure what that
even does a 6 and then B 5 break
looking forward to doing and I have that
in successfully can I get the a file now
the night is at least kicked away night
right here is a good move it's not
played though I thought it was a good
move Bishop where Knight right here I
should be playing maybe a lot sooner
than I did my queen should be shifting
over along that fifth rank mm-hmm wow my
pieces are sticking a little bit can I
get a quick mate on g2 no Queen trade
can have a queen trade aren't we pawns
on dark Bishop on light tension between
these rooks alright I don't want them to
be able to double no the night's gonna
hit that pond now they're in a pin I
want to press that for force that
forward and then maybe get this pawn
break in okay I think this is still good
in I was ready to play King here that
would have been a knight check that
would have been bad okay pawns on light
Bishop on dark oh yeah
pawns I'm light pawns on dark Bishop I'm
like you know what I'm trying to say oh
man quit trying to quit trying to
explain yourself just move you're down
on time the King is invading he's an
invader
he's an invader Oh dropping this pawn or
am i yes I am yes I am unless I have
something sneaky I would have had
something sneaky Bishop there is a
sneaky move sneaky move I think I could
do that no matter what they would have
played sneak attack the queen is on the
scene Queen is officially on that scene
right there two seconds remaining
anything anything at all no time no time
back to terminate e8 oh man
230 points 16 games in man what is going
on that seems like it's too much seems
like it's too much all right I'm gonna
try something sneaky here sneak attack
okay light squares light squares is
where I want to be King has to go to f7
I'm pretty sure about that one okay that
Knights dead Knight is officially dead
are we gonna have a quick resigner no we
are not could take here twice I'm not
going to though I want more development
and I'm hitting out twice it's
undefendable still I could still take
here next I just want more development
actually I'm gonna take here now since
it comes with the tempo on the Queen
I'll block a check with my bishop
unless there's that move Bishop f4 no
it's Castle pawn push I should have been
doing this move for about quite a bit I
think
avoid the Queen exchange give a check
over here and take on this square I
think no matter what I do that the Queen
goes too far I maybe get here they
resigned back determined to 3147 142 I'm
a long way off from confetti land
confetti land is where I need to be okay
I need a quick kill and I'm not getting
a single quick kill they're defending
against those sneaky moves against that
sneaky Knight g4 stuff they have seen
enough of it okay do I really want to
open up that okay I gotta go in this
direction I don't well I could have went
there
there's pond overextended I want to jump
my knight in to d3 and then my
light-square bishop comes out I could do
this and then follow up with this
advance if pawn push the door is slammed
on the bishop I have this diagonal
opened as well stay active right here
active my knight would actually like to
be there instead Knight right here could
be annoying
okay that's ruled out expanding on this
side and they are expanding on the other
side okay can I jump in here this bishop
is a very good defender stops pawn push
maybe I could just crash at that point
King up is probably purposeful get these
rooks out of here
rook right here next clean right here
ooh
clean right there might have been good
Queen trap Queen might get trapped if
they don't take my rook right now that's
an interesting move okay I'm gonna keep
the tension keep that tension okay open
up this file stop the knight from
getting here and now you know what maybe
I'll take this rook and then hit this
Queen and then get this pawn no I don't
know what I want to do Bishop here he's
gonna happen yes it is a dark square
Bishop is stupid dark square Bishop is
definitely stupid Oh maverick has to
come back or my King has to come back to
defend I should have maybe taken with
the other pond why'd I do that my bishop
is a big prisoner now huh it's okay
oh it's okay I have time advantage I'm
dropping this piece but maybe two or I
get the knight this can maybe even still
be tricky for white it's the advantage
of pawns okay whoa 250 187 I have to get
to 175 to get third whoa how many games
did I did I even play any games did I
even play okay and they e2 to g3 what do
we call this the tango reverse tango
difficulty casts difficulty castling now
for black I want to move my knight and
then push my F pawn open up the
file f5 is a very appealing square I'm
hitting the rook and I believe this
position is now going to be crumbling no
matter what just jump in here queen g4
is now available still a threat on g7
hitting g7 there's got to be Forks very
soon Forks or okay you know this is this
is big trouble now I could get this
bishop back with the Queen check and
maybe even throw my rook here soon and
get that other rope where is the mate I
just want to take that night with Czech
rep check next mate into threat mating -
threat making one threat that's me back
to chairman 148 148 192 I only have 13
games in IDI
know I don't know I don't want to resign
and they have 13 games in I shouldn't
have captured like that I don't like the
exchange karo in these one-minute errs
okay I did get a quick kill once though
out of this opening in a 1 minute in a 1
manager
look here Bishop back Queen d6 stuff the
knight moves then there's problems is he
gonna move I'm not gonna Castle I want
to do this I'm doing that on purpose
this Knight out of here take my knight
take like this and then remove that
night from defending h2 this Bishop out
of here back up my bishop and play g5
problems here I think think I that I
think that that's there in time although
Bishop here I could take on this square
first and I'm on the Queen oh no no no
no no no they take with check oh oh I
missed that it was taking with check ah
they took with check I forgot about that
you could still recover from this can
you be a good coordination
maybe they're nervous are they nervous I
can't ask my opponent are they nervous
let's open it up they might be scared
give a check come back here
I'm gonna take this cut the King off I'm
on the night as well give a check and
then take the night the Queen could play
here and give check ah
Oh what was that a mouse slip or
something ah it's tough
that's tough now that's me doctor term
of 168 310 227 195 whoa
not even close not even close even if I
won the game I live Oh what are they
just turn the house at me
to throw in the house at me is that what
it is
that's me back to tournament 188 oh it's
third-place confetti available Wow ah I
had a baby this is the baby step
variation of the Sicilian c6 and then c5
c6 and c5 everybody should be doing that
everybody loves to do what they love
losing tempo in just two moves oh man
this is such oh my
1:38 of once once square away is ready
to say I'm one square way Popeye the
pack leader
I play d4 correctly
I got d4 in this time I'm down in
Tottenham actually I made up the time
that was already lost can I put a dent
in the leader somehow hang on my knight
is tricky he is a tricky fella fella
Oh trickiness is that trickiness no not
really
I'm gonna be dropping that pun okay I
think there was that pond advance I'm
gonna keep some pieces let's do this run
away with my night run away with the
night okay hopefully you could turn out
to be a giant pest that is the plan
watch out for the tricky Forks where are
the forks right here I want to be can I
get a game back here can I win a game
actually okay where is the material over
here I want to clean train can we get
that clean trade okay we have a Queen
trade we'll watch out for the forks
they are very deadly watch out for those
deadly Forks rook over to g1 all right
here can I get rid of that Knight pawn
push I should probably get out of
checking distance and grab that pot look
activity rook activity here I'm dropping
that pawn where are those Forks any
Forks Oh what thanks for playing I
didn't get to try and win it was looking
good but it didn't matter that was not
gonna finish ah man good games oh would
I get 308 good games on 308 267 232 212
208 there was no recovering from that
loss and if I did I don't know if I
would even get up there it wasn't good
enough